what else could we try to do here who
else could we try to phone how about a
pizza place okay and i'll just order
tons of toppings let's do that okay got
i'll do that you got chocolate ice cream
do you know how to look that up dad yes
it's not
pizza
how old are you now oh i'll be 66 this
year i'm 65.
well you're pretty uh
presumptuous he does not what am i going
to look presumptuous that i'm going to
be 16. make 66. do i look like i'm about
to die no you don't you actually look
great thank you i look good he doesn't
know how to find a pizza number i do so
no you don't he typed in pizza and it's
like a whole bunch of websites recipes
he has no idea oh you did call i did
okay boom
amber calling this is for breakup for
delivery hey there's gwen
i'm sorry
i there know who you're asking for oh
i was asking for
yeah i don't know who that is okay
what's the name of your pizza place
pizza and pasta well yeah i was asking
for the owner but i guess he's not in
all right i would like to order a pizza
please
two pizzas i'm gonna be picking up our
delivery i'm gonna pick it up with cash
i got a lot of cash i'm trying to unload
here's what i'd like to have my name is
stu stu krenner that's with a k not a c
k credit i need the last name what would
you like to order all right on the first
pizza
i want it loaded
so we're gonna start with peppers
onions first of all sausage
say what
what size
the biggest one you got
and the second one's the smallest one
and that's really going to be loaded
[Music]
so recapping pizza give me one second
i think she's dumping me you think so
i don't think so
i think she's gonna come back
i think he's coming back
you think somebody came up to the
counter yeah they're just busy in the
store no one has patience what no one
has patience are you knocking our guests
no i mean the people on the phone oh
maybe i came a little too strong
no
i don't know that there's strength is an
issue with this person
hello
can i talk to who
yeah
what's the name of your place
so i want to speak is that a name of a
person or is that like some kind of a
pizza
it's a type of dough
i mean we could easily call her back now
let's do that
she wants you gave her your last name
and she goes no no no that's not
necessary that's too much information
here we go
how can i help you peppers onions
uh sausage on the first one
and on the second one i'm sorry i'm
sorry i got cut off from you i i got
disconnected somehow i'm caught stu
again
i'm not going to give you my last name
it's stew
so on the second pizza on the extra
large okay and the extra-large again
peppers
onions
sausage
tomatoes
sauce
three cheeses
swiss we don't have three cheeses we
have mozzarella cheese
all right three mozzarella cheeses are
you sure you're calling the right place
yeah this is right
yeah i'm very nice yeah oh very nice
yeah that's what i'm calling i'm right
down the street
i uh honestly i don't know who you're
trying to talk to there's no such thing
as oh okay because the restaurant
doesn't mean that's the owner okay
because my buddy uh my buddies he opened
up restaurants all over the place calls
him anyone if you're trying to be funny
oh believe me i'm hungry i'm trying to
be fed
so
we got let's recap we got peppers we got
onions we got tomatoes we got mozzarella
cheese three three different mozzarella
cheeses because it's got to be a three
cheese it's one
all right could you put it in three
globs three different gloves
i also like uh yellow peppers do you
have yellow peppers
hello
hello
oh i'm trying to order uh i don't know
if you have a new employee there or what
but i'm trying to order some pizzas i
like extra-large pizza
okay excellent extra large pepper onion
sauces and tomato i want it loaded i
want sausage tomatoes peppers onions
um
what are those peppers that you call the
hot ones
our green pepper no jalapenos jalapenos
jalapenos okay
yeah jalapenos and uh also uh
can you put like any kind of raisins on
there
raisins of pineapple you got pineapple
and barbecue
sauce ah okay i just want this loaded my
wife loves loaded pizza
oh okay okay
so pete
who am i speaking with again
okay you say one extra large one with
green pepper onion sauces tomato and
jalapenos yeah but not in that order
not in that order
i can start with uh i wanna i want the
california roll spicy tuna wings on the
pizza
you got that
[Music]
californian spicy and the wind yeah
california roll
spicy tuna i got it there last week
and then wings on the pizza
chicken wings
chicken wing and pizza on the pizza on
the top and chocolate you have chocolate
just to make it sweet
no no no no i know
hang on a second he doesn't have
chocolate oh hey we can do it
you want to talk up you got salty you
got oh you got almonds
oh he doesn't want almonds i'm sorry he
doesn't wanna
he doesn't want it
yeah he's one almonds he's on a
ventilator so he can't have almonds okay
let's go with
can you put raisins on there
rice in the in the windows uh raisins on
the extra-large pizza next to the
peppers only next to the green peppers
i want raisins he wants rice
razor raisins i'm sorry raisins
[Music]
but i want to be able to pick it up
because i can't leave him very long he's
on a ventilator
i want razor he wants raisins can you
should i pick up if i brought raisins in
could you put them on the pizza
i want raisins
[Music]
[Laughter]
i think you just call back and say
you're cancer in the order but you just
want raisins
are you calling again always
hey my dad called
you
you want to you speak to my son you get
to help me speak to my son
my dad
hello
hello
it's nice when a pizza place takes place
they won't answer calls it's like dinner
time
we have found the one real estate agent
that won't answer a call a travel agent
that won't book anything in a pizza
place that will talk to nobody
this is ridiculous oh here we calling
there we go
how can i help you yeah listen i just
try to order pizza my my father just yes
you could go ahead and place it i was
just going to say that thank you yeah
i'll come i'll come down there but he
just wants raisins now let me put them
on the phone with you hello
hello
myself another
tell her what you want real quick can i
speak to the gentleman
can i she hung up
i think she's done let's go down there
come on let's get down
just stand at the
[Laughter]
yeah you guys should go find it and
videotape yourselves outside there
asking for raisins
i like to go through drive-throughs at a
restaurant like a mcdonald's any kind of
fast food place and just you know
just i'm like two ice creams one a
chocolate one vanilla cone
and make sure the chocolate is the
chocolate and the bananas have been in
it and i pull around and they get handed
to me i go okay which one's a chocolate
[Laughter]
isn't it fun when this is i do those
things all the time my wife goes but
who's the joke they just think you're an
idiot my son loves it he'll be sitting
there in the back and i'll be
so we have a cappuccino
[Laughter]
[Music]
you